as we master things they become less
conscious to us the more we understand
and the more we know the more we can
allow that to fall below the level of
explicit
consciousness mcgill christ welcome to
the show
oh thank you very much chris delighted
to be here
what is the vision that you've got for
your work because you've spent uh
decades multiple decades researching and
writing i'm interested by what the
outcome is
that's driven you to do
this much work
well the outcome remains to be seen but
what has um
driven me if you like and it is almost
like feeling that
i've been possessed by a demon that's
driving me to write
um against my will at times and and to
complete exhaustion at times but
i think that the serious point and
it's an enormous project
these two very long books but the point
is can be said relatively simply that
all my life and i mean you know
certainly all my
life since my early teens i felt that
much of the picture that we are taught
about the world or not so much taught as
it were in school but just received from
pundits and
media and so on it's it's completely
wrong this idea that the world is um
completely unresponsive a lump of stuff
for us to grab when we need it do what
we please with and none of this actually
has any meaning so we might as well just
get on and be greedy
um
this seems to me to
miss just about every significant point
um that that i can feel about the
business of existence which is
extraordinary mysterious i mean first of
all why is there anything what are we
doing here and it's these questions who
are we actually and i think at the
moment just as an aside
i think there's a very worrying
extremely worrying and very rapid
tendency to accentuate something that's
been going on all my lifetime which is
the idea of man as a machine
what is the natural world um and the
universe that surrounds it and what are
we doing here in it i mean what's the
relationship between us and whatever
else there is so these are pretty
fundamental questions you wouldn't
expect me to give a very short answer
but that's the
what i've hoped to have done
um
is at least to have given people
a lot to think about and very good
confidence in
institutions they often have themselves
that this way of looking at the world is
uh intellectually impoverished morally
bankrupt and spiritually dead
and that it's not something that they
feel is at all um like
the experience they have of being alive
so it's it's on that sort of a scale i'm
afraid which is why the second book that
i just published the matter with things
this is as you know a rather long book
1400 pages yes
i think that's once once it's over a
thousand i think it's technically a tome
that's when you're allowed to refer to
it as a tome
but we're now making more uh rational
rules around stuff that probably
shouldn't have them what's the what's
the common thread
that ties all of the work together
because it bridges theology
philosophy
psychology neuroscience
all sorts of stuff what's this is there
a common thread between those
yes i think there is first of all i
can't resist a little crack on the word
tome because
somebody wrote to me calling my book and
i mean it was a an innocent missed type
my tomb t-o-m-b uh which do you think
that's actually kind of true yeah i felt
like i've been dead
because i felt i felt it kind of um um
pretty much killed me anyway
what is the common thread
you you mentioned a number of threads
and i suppose that they all the fact
that they all seem to me coherent with
one another rather than in competition
with one another is one of the threads
i've all my life moved backwards and
forwards between
um what would nowadays be thought of as
rather separate even perhaps
incompatible
ways of thinking about and being in the
world for example
my father
was a doctor his father was a doctor my
other grandfather was a scientist and i
was brought up with a very
um
you know i i think a live interest in
curiosity about things scientific but
then when um i got old enough to
not just be a little sort of brain on
legs but actually have feelings i in my
teens i started to realize how very much
this all left out
and i studied much more what one what i
call the humanities and then i got a
fellowship in oxford in which i could
research in the area of the philosophy
of literature and philosophy more
generally and i got interested in the
mind body problem and that drew me to
actually wanting to study
medicine
a long haul in this country uh six years
before you're qualified and then another
eight before you become a specialist in
whatever it is at least um so i
the thought there was that only by
actually having experience of what
happens when something goes wrong with
somebody's brain and it affects their
mind when something goes wrong with
their mind and it affects their whole
body can i really crack these
interesting issues
about how these
various strands philosophy science and
laterally physics although i'm no
physicist but i have a lot of friends
who um are willing to guide me and make
sure i'm not saying things that don't
make sense but the extraordinary thing
is that all of these strands seem to me
to be leading to a similar place a place
which in fact for thousands of years the
wisdom literature around the world has
been leading
one that is quite different from this
image of
ourselves or the universe as chaotic
pointless
purposeless meaningless
uh and there to be exploited but instead
something with which we have a natural
um deep deep spiritual connection
and which is beautiful rich complex and
constantly unfolding and it's our
purpose if you like to be part of that
unfolding so that's really
what holds it together and brings
together as you say in the book this
first
third of it is mainly neuroscience but
trying to show the philosophical
implications of that the second section
is epistemology how do we know anything
and the third is metaphysics what is
that what is there in this universe so i
look at things like time and space and
matter and consciousness but also things
like values and the sense of the sacred
and the idea of the coincidence of
opposites which i think is a huge
uh problem for us nowadays we don't
understand that opposites often come
together and we push further and further
in one direction ignorantly thinking
we'll get further away from something
we're trying to avoid only to meet it um
head on as we push too far in any one
direction what's an example of that
well there are many i suppose uh one
other controversial one would be that
just about every people's republic of
whatever in its zeal for republicanism
and freedom has created a tyranny in
which the people are subjected to
the most um
draconian control and i think there are
variations of this going on
uh now uh in
in the politics of the public sphere
um in politics in the more sort of
twitter sphere
and
i don't think we understand the way in
which
the beautiful
and the ugly can come together by too
much pursuing one we can find the other
and they're never completely apart the
good and the bad there are things that
we think these this just is good
um but there's nothing that just is good
things are good only in a context when
you take them out of the context or push
them too far things become unbalanced
they fall out of harmony and as in music
you get a terrible discord
so i think this is an idea we could do
with them taking on board in in our
modern world
one of the things that i found
interesting is you've been working at
this for a long time and you suggested
that your intuition around this lack of
intuition and
i guess a view of quite a sterile
view of the world um that this has been
something that's
been
bubbling under the surface for yourself
for a long time which means it must have
existed before you started working on it
and yet
yes i know it feels like
a lot of the problems that we see that
might have been around for a long time
are quite easy to
drop at the feet of big tech or of the
super modern era you know last
10 to 30 years something like that um
but it seems like this is a obviously a
problem which has been going on for much
longer than that
yes it is um and in my
earlier book um the master and his
emissary which came out in 2009 so
12 and a half years ago now um
the second half of the book i look
through the history of western of the
western world
um looking at the way in which the
balance between the take on the world of
the two hemispheres we haven't really
talked about that yet but um let me go
straight to that that the brain is
divided of course the two hemispheres
work together but they also attend to
the world in a different way and know
and understand quite different things
and once you see that you can begin to
see what happens when things get out of
balance out of kilter and there seems to
be a tendency in civilization to begin
interestingly rather well balanced and
then to go out of balance further and
further in the direction of privileging
the left hemisphere which um
spoiler alert is the less intelligent
the less perceptive the less insightful
of the two which doesn't make it
pointless or bad it just means it ought
to know its place and not try to be the
master uh as in the
the um the the narrative the myth that
uh this the title the master and his
ministry comes from
so um
yes i think it does go back much further
but
technology is a very interesting special
case you can talk about technology going
back thousands of years or you can talk
about the first smelting of iron being
technology and so on that's that's true
in a way
um but
with many technologies and i think we
see that very clearly now there is
something marvelous in
the technology up to a certain point but
by extending it further and further we
don't necessarily make it better we
actually may make things considerably
worse i mean there are everyday examples
of this that as machines
it becomes um
the rigor for for a producer of a
washing machine or whatever it is to put
more and more and more controls on it it
gets actually harder to use it
and um
cars now are so um overburdened with
electronic um
gizmos and gadgets that it's often very
hard actually to control your own car
the way you would like it it's so
complex and so difficult to finesse that
in fact um a much simpler car would be a
much better thing to be driving so i
mean that's just obviously on the very
simple level but i think technology is
no more no less
than the extension of human control
that's exactly what technology is
and obviously to some degree
to have some control over what happens
around one is a good thing
although
even there the philosophy that you can
sort things out um and you ought to be
in control of them rather than
um i think a wiser idea that you take
what comes to you and take the
advantages out of it rather than
resisting it and trying to make it into
something it isn't
um but in any case to go back to what i
was saying technology is
the extension of human power to control
the environment
society
people
uh and this is neither in itself good
nor bad i would say although it ought to
give rise to a little bit of fear um
in any case but it's how it's used and
to what end and
to have a sudden proliferation of the
capacity to control
um perhaps destroy nature and humanity
um
without any commensurate increase in
wisdom
is a huge problem for us i don't notice
i was getting wiser in fact i i'd be
prepared to say that this is probably
the least wise
civilization of which we have any record
how would you define wisdom
uh i wouldn't necessarily define it at
all i think there are certain things if
you don't know them when you see them um
a definition is not going to help you
and indeed that of course is the left
hemisphere's idea well let's get this
cut and dried and clear at the outset so
what is the soul what is meant by god
what is etcetera now the point is that
in areas of very real experience that we
all respond to there are things for
which we don't have terms that can be
simply defined but to ignore them just
because we don't have those terms is
extremely dangerous
but let me not dodge your problem
if i can
in any way begin to answer it
i think what i'd say it's the capacity
to balance
many different
ways in which we come to know something
about the world and not be simply um
under the um
sway of one of them so in the middle of
the book i look at science
reason intuition and imagination as
probably the four ways that most people
would come up with for saying how do we
get to know something about reality how
do we get to know anything that's truer
than anything else
and i think my conclusion there is that
we've lost the balance we think that one
of these or two at the most can answer
all our questions and they can't
we need to bring to bear
a number of different
strands of knowledge in order to have
wisdom
and i i won't go into the detail but in
greek there were
four or five important words for
knowledge
and um there was also separately wisdom
sofia and
they showed an enormous sophistication
in their understanding of what these
things were
but
nowadays
we seem to think that if something is
rationalistic in the way that a computer
could follow it then we've achieved a
full understanding of something
but that actually very rarely leads to a
full understanding indeed there is a
condition in which people can only reach
conclusions by reasoning about them not
by experience and not by intuition and
it's not that rare it's called
schizophrenia
and schizophrenia is of course the
archetypal example of what used to be
called madness and we used to say that
people when they were mad lost their
reason but in fact this has been pointed
out schizophrenia is not a condition in
which people have lost their reasons but
have lost everything but their reason
and they can only come to conclusions on
a rational basis so um a thought comes
into their head from their unconscious
so they don't remember giving rise to it
so somebody must be beaming thoughts
into my head they hear a sound in the uh
coming from the other side of the wall
and they think somebody is there bugging
me and so this is entirely rational but
it is actually completely unlikely and
the problem is they have no sense
from experience and from intuition of
what we should understand i i will
stop this but i just want to make this
point before doing so
intuition has had a very bad rap lately
because some um clever and entertaining
psychologists pointed out that quite
often it's mistaken which it is as i
pointed out
quite often uh reasoning can lead you to
very mistaken conclusions if you lead
your life only by reasoning you'll be a
very strange person things won't work
well
um but these these occasions on which
intuition doesn't work are much rarer
than we think i make the um comparison
with
optical illusions which are fascinating
and sometimes you can hardly believe
your eyes as we say but i don't know
anyone who after seeing a really good
optical illusion says um that does it
from now on i'm going to leave my life
with my eyes shut uh no because most of
the time you're asking a bloody good job
and the same is true of intuition
and
one point that
is worth just finishing on here is that
if we have to argue explicitly and
rationally for a conclusion only we can
express only one line of thinking
whereas in intuition we may bring
together
simultaneously and balance without even
having to work through it explicitly
many strands
of knowledge the wisdom that we have
gathered from experience
and it's been argued and i very much
support this that
decision makers who are the head of
important corporations whether private
or governmental should be encouraged to
use their intuition instead of reducing
their intelligence by following
programmatic
algorithms
i agree this is a tension that i've been
feeling in myself and
talking to friends about it's very
interesting
when you have a conversation that
continues to crop up
in different circumstances and it's
always got this single thread that ties
them all together and the one of the
most common ones that i'm seeing at the
moment is a a tension between cognition
and intuition that
maybe it's because of the age i'm at as
well in early 30s
a lot of the solutions that me and my
friends found to problems throughout our
20s was to apply cerebral horsepower to
it right that i'm going to just
use more
thinking and i'm going to think myself
through this problem
and then you realize that maybe that was
a good tool that got you across one
river but you're now trying to carry
that boat across river across land to
then get you something next and what's
next for a lot of us i think is
trying to feel and find more grace and
play
and
being able to aggregate all of the
experience that we've got and this maybe
makes sense actually because
when you're first starting out at
something
you need to be more deliberate because
you don't have that intuition to fall
back on and yet now exactly the
situation that i'm finding myself in
increasingly is i'm trying to
switch off that rational thinking brain
i'm trying to utilize as much intuition
as i can
well i mean obviously it's a common
place that um
that young people are more certain than
their elders and
are certain because they've worked it
all out
i mean in the old days people used to go
to university in order to learn from
people who were perhaps three times
their age had thought and read an
enormous amount but nowadays they go in
order to tell those older people what
they should be thinking and what they
should be saying well this seems to me
to be um
would be very funny if it weren't so
completely tragic um it's destroying our
society
so yes as we get older we realize that
there's far more to it than anything
that can be just worked out like a
logical puzzle
and that only people with um fairly
severe autistic tendencies fall into
doing that
so
yes our intuitions are terribly terribly
important and one of the things that
used to be part of education was
teaching people not in a i hope um
in such a way as to suppress
their
interest in making something new but
to enable them to make something new
which was the history of
their culture
if you like the um tradition
now i mean unfortunately we now think of
tradition as clearly must be wrong silly
explanations of people that didn't know
what was happening
didn't know enough and so on and so we
can dispense with all that but the
trouble is that when you do
you become very rudderless and rather
foolish and the things you come up with
are not interesting or helpful
innovations
the point i would like to make is that
tradition knowing the tradition is the
only way in which you can
evolve to something new traditions are
always changing a tradition is like a
river
a river is as it were always there the
river outside my house was there
yesterday and i imagine it'll be there
tomorrow
but the water in it is changing all the
time and it's moving on so
this process is what we have as a
society once we throw out
all of it we negate it we rubbish it we
have all kinds of
more or indeed less sophisticated um
thoughts about it then we lose the
capacity for something to evolve a
society
a human society a civilization is more
like a plant
than a machine
it with a plant if you want it to go
somewhere you train it that way you you
you lead it you don't cut it off at the
root and stick it on a wall because
that's where you want it to go it'll
just die and fall off and we can't make
these things these plants do what they
don't want to do but what we can do is
kill them a gardener as i often say
can't make a plant can't even make a
plant grow can only just allow a plant
to flourish or not and at the moment
we're not allowing
that
wonderful flowering of a civilization of
culture of society
instead we're killing it
it does relate to a belief that we are
able to
reality is infinitely malleable because
of our access to technological prowess
if we can fly around the world if we can
put a man on the moon if we can do
whatever then why can't we dot dot dot
there's a donald kingsbury quote which i
love that says tradition is a set of
solutions for which we have forgotten
the problems throw away the solution yes
and you get the problem back sometimes
the problem has mutated or disappeared
often it is still there as strong as it
ever was
exactly
yes
um
what can i say to anthony i disagree um
what i think um
you're referring to when you say we
think we've got the answers to things
is rather like the story of the
sorcerer's apprentice which um was
familiar to people of my great age
because of a disney film called fantasia
but uh
it it's a it's an old um german myth um
best preserved in the poem by goethe um
in which um
the apprentice of a sorcerer overhears
the sorcerer um casting spells and
getting things to come to life and do
work for him and so when the master goes
out and says would you mind sweeping the
room while i'm out he thinks no i know
the spell i'm going to get the broom and
the bucket to clean the room but
unfortunately having started it has no
idea how to stop it well that's a a myth
a and in the end nearly drowns except
that the sorcerer comes back in the nick
of time and
it says the thing that the sort of the
sort of apprentice doesn't know and
stops the process so we're as foolish as
the apprentice and just because you know
how to make things happen doesn't mean
you have understanding of them that
could two completely different things
and what i worry about is at the moment
we increasingly have the power to
interfere
in what a human being is there are you
know i don't want to um
join with the most extremely um paranoid
narratives but i think there is a very
true and real and balanced
um
risk that we run of
um
robbing human beings of humanity
turning them into what would only really
be rather secondary machines because
when we compare ourselves to machines we
just find the machines do everything
faster but that's because they had they
didn't do any of the things that we do
and so my
very big worry um
pretty much equal to
the worry the overwhelming worry about
whether there will be a world
in which we can live in the future
given how much we're doing to destroy it
um
my very real concern is that even if the
world survived we would have actually
succeeded in destroying humanity which
is quite incredible because at the
moment humanity is the most
sophisticated outcome of
uh evolution that we know it's a very
heavy price to pay you know in order to
save the world you have to destroy the
things that you cared about within it
well that's what we're doing whether we
like it or not we're destroying
the beauty and life of nature and we're
destroying ourselves and our society
there's a quote from confucius uh that
edward slingalin put in trying not to
try which i wanted to bring up earlier
on about um the individual's requirement
to balance this cognition and intuition
this deliberateness in the beginning and
the naturalness afterward in the early
stages of training an aspiring confucian
gentleman needs to memorize entire
shelves of archaic texts learn the
precise angle at which to bow and learn
the lengths of the steps with which he
is entered to enter a room his sitting
mat must always be perfectly straight
all of this rigor and restraint however
is ultimately aimed at producing a
cultivated but nonetheless genuine form
of spontaneity indeed the process of
training is not considered complete
until the individual has passed
completely beyond the need for thought
or effort and that's the
deliberate to intuitive
um tension that i think that we're
playing with and then as you say it
rolls out onto a civilizational level as
well
and what you've referred to uh is
something we all have direct experience
of
um i have it as a doctor but if you're a
chess player or a pilot you would have a
similar um
understanding which is that when you
start out on this process you have to
learn and memorize and think consciously
about many many things but by the time
you're a skillful physician or surgeon a
skillful chess player or a skillful
pilot you don't think like that because
that would make you a very second-rate
uh performer of whatever that skill is
only being able to let go of that degree
of control allows you to be the true
expert and you know when somebody does
one of these great feats like um the
pilot who landed a plane on the hudson
river um afterwards was asked how did
you do it i don't know i just i just did
it which is as much as to say that
as we master things they become
less conscious to us the more we
understand and the more we know the more
we can allow that to fall below the
level of explicit consciousness
and that explicit consciousness is not
the hallmark of excellence or
intelligence uh or understanding
it's a regrettable thing that we have to
do sometimes
when there's a problem that we need to
be able to do away with but as long as
things don't
uh bring up a problem of a new kind then
we should not be thinking in that
explicit way because we will we will
react and respond
poorly
didn't you look at horse racing and isle
of man
uh superbike racing as well for this
yes i did and it came to me rather than
from my will
rather nicely um
somebody who is a physician who looks
after the health of the tt races the
race on this amazing natural course in
the isle of man uh approached me with
some observations about what he knew of
the bikers who are traveling on ordinary
roads with all the things like road
repairs pop holes um
walls
sudden right angle bends
and uh often achieve speeds of 200 miles
an hour in doing so it is it's been i
think with justice called the most
dangerous sporting activity in the world
but um they have to rely very very
heavily on things that they mustn't um
be clunkily consciously aware of they
have to be able to master a lot of
things unconsciously and the same thing
happened to me with a man who had
started his life as
a worker with horses a trainer of horses
he did a
a phd in animal physiology he as a young
man had a hundred criteria whereby he
would be able to select a really
excellent racehorse
and then he found in his
latter years that he was working as a
tipster on these tracks and he was
completely dumbfounded but i couldn't
explain how it was that after looking at
a horse for perhaps half a minute
walking around in the in the circle
before the race he was able to put um
winning um bets on these things and to
begin with he doubted himself and that
would bring up the
bookmakers and say
why did i say that no no no make it
something else and in the end they got
so frustrated because his first guess
was right and his second guess was wrong
they just said to him just text us your
first thought and don't talk about it or
think about it after that and as long as
he does that he makes um a salary in um
six figures but if he starts thinking
about it he's no better than chance
isn't that beautiful
it's it's genuinely it's kind of like
real world magic
you know this fact that you can
aggregate all of this
information and yet if someone forced
you to try and concretize it into words
you wouldn't
have the first idea about why it was the
case and
another thing
that you've identified there is this
this tension
uh within our own brains which is the
subject of your first book so if someone
hasn't been introduced to the
um left and right brain split that we
have and how that characterizes its
thought patterns and behavior how would
you explain that to someone
well i i'd say that they've evolved
for two purposes
one the right hemisphere in order to
enable us to understand as much of the
complex
experience that we have as possible and
the other to enable us to use the world
quickly to be able to grab stuff
and manipulate the world so i sometimes
say the left hemisphere enables us to
apprehend the world in sense of grasping
hold of it in fact it literally controls
the right hand with which we grasp
things um and the aspects of language
not all of language but the bits where
we say i've got it i've grasped it i've
pinned it down
and the right hemisphere not to
apprehend but to comprehend the world
and one way of thinking of this is that
the left hemisphere schematizes
um it's the hemispheres theory it has a
theory about how things work
um the right hand
uh is not the hemisphere of theory so
much as of experience it understands
what it's seeing
and if you are trying to navigate this
world it's very often useful to have a
map and the left hemisphere holds the
map the trouble is that the left
hemisphere encourages us to think that
the map is the same thing as the world
that is mapped but the world that is
mapped is
hundreds of thousands of times
infinitely more complex than the map
that doesn't make the map useless in
fact what makes the map useful is it has
very little information on it if it had
too much information we couldn't use it
but we have fallen into the habit of
thinking that it's very impoverished
schematized theoretical
um
dogmatic view of how the world works
what people are and and all the rest
that that that is the reality whereas in
fact it's what is obscuring the reality
so
what we need to do is to get back to a
situation where the right hemisphere is
as it were the one
that is in
control or mastery of the situation
that unfortunately the left hemisphere
when it thinks it knows everything um
things start to go wrong
and and this was
summed up in a saying that's attributed
to einstein but certainly very much in
his spirit
the the rational mind is the faithful
servant and the intuitive mind a
precious gift we live in the society
which honors the servant but has
forgotten the gift and really the only
purpose in the rational mind is if it
can help us get to where that intuitive
mind can make
itself felt and interestingly in science
although there's a lot of very plodding
pedestrian
uh serial thought that needs to go on
all the great breakthroughs are not made
by that process at all they're not made
by the scientific method as it's called
they are made actually as
the stories of pretty much all great
scientists including in
perhaps most strikingly in the case of
einstein come as intuitive insights that
they often can't explain and then
months later they do all the pedestrian
work that shows them why they were in
fact right there are many examples in my
book
so
yes we need to balance these things but
two things to say the first is that the
left hemisphere sees this relationship
as competitive as either
or either the left hand side or the
right hemisphere whereas the right
hemisphere sees both and it knows that
it needs the information the left hand
the left hemisphere gives
but it's just that it all that
information means nothing unless it's
taken up into a big picture and there it
has its true value if you stop at where
the left hemisphere is you're left with
a bunch of meaningless fragments of
senseless data which leads people who
have stopped at that point to say oh the
world's just made up of little bits that
don't mean anything that's because their
right hemisphere with which they could
put together the context and see
everything in context would be able to
understand it so that's one point that
they see things differently and the
other is that the less you see the more
you think you know
this is actually a phenomenon in human
psychology known as the dunning-kruger
effect people who really don't know very
much think they know everything as
people begin to know more and more they
see that they know less and less
so
probably the left hemisphere thinks it
knows it all yes
functionally how is this uh
manifesting in the brain so you're
talking about the fact that the left
hemisphere sees almost an antagonistic
sort of adversarial relationship with
itself and the right and yet the right
is able to work more cooperatively but
functionally what does this mean for
what's happening inside of our brains
i don't know quite at what level you're
saying functionally but i mean
is there some sort of one-way one-way
street from left to right
well
the right hemisphere communicates more
and more quickly with the left
hemisphere than the left hemisphere does
with the right although for what the
right hemisphere
knows to be valuable it needs to get
that information back to the right
hemisphere um that's a very simple
example but when you look at as i do at
length in this new book um at the
examples of patients and what they teach
us what we see is that the left house
who really understands next to nothing
but thinks it knows everything so you
get this extraordinary situation that
somebody will deny something as
absolutely barn door as that the left
half of their body is paralyzed they
will completely deny it
and say no everything's fine and it all
works and so on and so they're
very good at denying and they just don't
understand what it is the right
hemisphere is talking about so when
people lose
um their right hemisphere through
perhaps a stroke or an injury or much of
the function of it at any rate
they become incapable of understanding
what's going on they don't know what
people say what they mean what does what
does the meaning of the way this person
is talking or behaving they can as it
were
they've got a dictionary and they can
look the words up and they've got rules
of grammar but the thing doesn't really
mean what it means because things only
mean what they mean in a context and
sometimes the context can completely
change the meaning which is why sound
bites from what somebody has said taken
out of context and whizzed around the
world
should be treated with the contempt that
they deserve not suddenly become um oh i
see you say we can now
wage war on this particular person you
don't know in what context that was said
or what other things that person uh
believes or means
what i have a slightly
i i just have a slightly amusing example
of the context changing things which i
can't resist and which is cereal package
so in the supermarket there are four
sizes of cereal packets there's one
called jumbo which means very large and
then comes one called economy which
means large
then there comes one called family and
that means medium and finally there's
large which means small
but anyway sorry about that chris carry
on
that sounds like something that rory
sutherland would have told me
so if you were to
characterize uh somebody who only had
access to the left brain and somebody
who only had access to their right brain
whether that be through a stroke or
through an unfortunate piece of steel
that's gone through the top of their
head um
how would their behavior differ
well the person with the left hemisphere
stroke would have obvious
um impediments
mainly and usually to do with speech
and the use of the right hand and given
that
um depends what you mean by being
right-handed because it's a matter of
degree rather than absoluteness but
89 of us are probably right-handed so
for most people a left hemisphere stroke
has
two obvious disadvantages communicating
and grasping
and
however
when there is a problem with the right
hemisphere
the whole of that person's world altars
they as i say
they cease to have proper empathy one of
the hardest things for people caring for
people after right hemisphere injuries
or strokes is that they no longer seem
to have empathy they don't sympathize
they don't understand what other people
mean they lose what in psychology is
called theory of mind which means oh i
see what's going on in that person's
mind they no longer understand it
um and they are really not able to
function at more than a very simple
mechanistic level
but because they still have preserved
speech
and they still can use their right hand
doctors have not paid that much
attention to them historically they
discharged them from hospital and say
well you know thank goodness it wasn't a
left hemisphere they're still functional
they're just a functional [ __ ]
if you like
and you know great um
epiphany or sort of aha moment for me
was to come across the work of my
colleague john cutting who had
painstakingly
sat
at the bedside of patients who had
things wrong with their right hemisphere
and realized how just how crazy their
world was the amazingly bizarre things
that they believed and the things that
they denied and the things they made up
and once you realize that you see why it
is true
that the rehabilitation
of somebody after a left hemisphere
stroke but in which they may have lost
their speech and used to the right hand
is much easier than rehabilitating
somebody after the right hemisphere is
true have you got any idea
why
the brain would have developed in this
way i don't understand why it would be
adaptive
to distribute differing characteristics
based on some arbitrary contralateral
line
it's a very important and interesting
question
um
in order to help us see what we're
dealing with this is not something that
arose in humans
it's true in all animals we've looked at
and i don't just mean mammals
and i don't just mean
animals in the normal sense also in
insects and in
worms and in the most ancient
still surviving creature a cn anemone
called nemesistelovic tenses which is
700 million years old it already and
it's taken to be the first example of a
neural net
in any living creature its neural net is
already asymmetrical 700 million years
ago and
every creature has this asymmetry now
you might well say but why because the
world isn't asymmetrical in that way
it's it's it's it's um
it sounds like a a big error but to me
um
i i think a lot of people would agree
with me but my belief is that this
arises because of the need to solve a
very basic conundrum that all living
things have how to get stuff
including food and stuff that you can
use like getting a twig to build a nest
and all that but at the same time
watch out for everything else that's
going on so if you were just narrowly
targeted on picking up a great piece of
grain on the background of grit uh if
you're a bird you know
you you would soon end up being someone
else's lunch while you got yours because
you wouldn't be seeing the predators and
you wouldn't be seeing um
your family your con specifics with whom
you should be sharing the food and so on
so we need all creatures need to do two
things at once keep a broad lookout and
focus on a target so they need to focus
on something that they get but be
looking out for the predators and the
whole of the rest of what's going on and
that effectively runs all the way
through two kinds of attention
one very narrow very narrow three
degrees probably out of 360 degrees so
tiny like a little window on the world
that's very sharply focused and the
other seeing the broad picture sustained
over many
seconds or minutes
so
from one kind of attention the world
seems to be made up of tiny unconnected
fragments that are like little stabs in
the world that somehow got to be
connected to make sense whereas to the
other hemisphere the right hemisphere
the world is made up of things that are
continuous that um
that flow um that always change they're
not made up of static snapshots but
actually part of as i would say
something like a flow or a river
that are multiply multiply connected in
fact ultimately connected to everything
else um
that you know where the stuff that is
not explicit is important whereas the
left hemisphere only understands the
explicit meaning can't understand a joke
can't understand a metaphor uh it takes
everything very literally so if you
if you look at that you can see that
they give rise to in humans so two quite
different worlds a meaningless
heap of stuff for us to exploit and on
the other hand a vast richly complex
moving flowing
tapestry of existence that has rich deep
meaning into which we are connected so
these are quite quite different
versions of the world and what i do in
in the matter with things is to discuss
how we can use this information to help
us decide
what the reality is to some extent we
can't know ultimate truth of course i
don't suggest we can but we must make
at least gradual
decisions that certain things are truer
than others otherwise we'd not know what
to think or do we couldn't get out of
bed so i'm really trying to help us
decide what the world is like and how we
should get to know it
given the fact that you've just
displayed two different worlds there the
one that's predominantly left brain and
one that's right brain the one that's
right brain sounds
significantly nicer to me that sounds
lovely why is it then that we appear to
have a bias of drifting toward the left
both
individually and specifically
civilizationally as well
brilliant question um
individually i'm not sure that we do
unless we belong to the society which is
doing it so really the question is more
about why do societies do this and then
the individuals reflect the norms or the
preferences that they think the society
says
right yep yep yep
exactly but i don't think that it's um a
good generalization that over a lifetime
people become more reliant on their left
hemisphere i'd say they give more and
more reliance to their right hemisphere
actually
um
although i believe the very end of life
that process might maybe reverse it
rather depends on the process that's
causing dementia if we're talking about
dementia anyway i don't want to get into
all that
um
but the question why do civilizations go
this way is is a very interesting one
and um in the preface to the new edition
of the master and his industry i point
to about six ways it's only a very short
essay it's about 15 pages long but i'd
point to about six reasons that
societies do this
one of the most obvious is that using
the left hemisphere
um
simply enables you to become
[Music]
good at grabbing things
and as societies grow
people see more and more power
disposable to them
and people who are interested in
self-aggrandizement and
the annexation of power
psychopaths narcissists tend to drift to
the top of civilizations and we can
certainly see this being enacted
for us in europe at the moment
so does that
um
it makes us feel that we're we're good
at grabbing and
civilizations usually overextend
themselves before they collapse they
create an empire
um and in this case i think the most
dangerous thing is the um commercial
empire
of the west although we may begin to
lose that soon
but this business of having an empire
thinking you can control large areas of
the world feed straight into using the
left hemisphere and also
once you get outside of decisions that
are being made within the context
where they're relevant
made by huge
um governmental bodies perhaps for a
whole empire literally across the world
more and more it's impossible to make um
the sort of decisions the wise decisions
the balance decisions the right
hemisphere would make because that would
mean taking into account individual
context everywhere so instead something
is as is a rolled out
which is a
one-size-fits-all simple algorithmic
thing where you can follow the rules
tick the boxes and bingo we've killed a
civilization and
another thing is it's very very easy it
to express the view of the left
hemisphere it's money for old rope which
is why it's so easy for clever dicks to
come along and go
no to believe that there's
anything real except just stuff and
machines and
and thinking
the idea that there's a perhaps a spirit
or a soul
that's just ridiculous it's so easy to
argue that um because as it were the
left hemisphere's picture which is the
one that language is designed to put
across doesn't talk about the weapons
of language lends itself more towards
that type of discussion yes
except the language of poetry the
language of
myth the language of narrative the
language of ritual these things actually
express the powerful things that we
crave that we feel are absent from the
kind of electronic manual um out of
which we're increasingly encouraged to
speak nowadays the first one was it's
easier it's more competitive the left
brain seems to be better at competing
the second one was that it seems to be
better at coordinating and the third one
was it seems to be better at
communicating
i suppose so yes i mean you could you
could put that i mean it's not really
better at communicating because
communication
is very subtle business when i speak to
you you're taking in all the things my
right hemisphere does which is to make
my voice not sound like a computer
generated
so you're getting your tone of voice my
facial expression my body language
you're also getting jokes you're getting
metaphors you're understanding what's
going on so actually communication is
much more the right hemispheres thing
it's more effective at communicating at
low resolutions though or definitely
communicating at scale simplifying the
world into a lower resolution version of
what it is putting it out there easy to
understand yeah i can see i mean those
that's a satisfactory explanation i like
uh easy ways to remember things so uh
competition coordination and
communication uh keeping those
there is is gonna
help help me to to do that
rolling the clock forward
are you optimistic about the future
how do you feel
um i call myself um
a hopeful pessimist
um
actually quite often the truth can only
be expressed in a paradox but what i
mean by that is that
i think to be hopeful
is a duty and a virtue and a strength
and we never know quite what's going to
happen it's only the left hemisphere
that thinks that kind of thing so
i can't rule out that we may have as we
have occasionally in the past a sudden
change of direction
which is happens
extensively and fast
fast enough to save us and to save the
destruction of life on this planet
but i'm not very hopeful because
um technological changes are going on so
fast
um
exponentially faster and putting power
in the hands of the least
um savory people um the least
intelligent
uh
the most manipulative um and the people
we don't want to be making decisions
about our own future even if we wanted
anyone to be making those decisions
so the situation doesn't look good
there are a number of reasons for
thinking it might get better and one is
that the message that i have is um
something that seems to resonate
with people at all stages of their life
so if i
travel in lecture which i've done rather
less recently because of covid and i
usually find that afterwards as many
young people are sort of passionately
asking me what do we do how can we help
themselves in this situation um
and of course i don't have a single
ready answer but the fact that they
see that there's a problem here and need
to resist what's happening is incredibly
important often just resisting a process
or changing a process that you know has
been bad is the most important thing for
example if a patient comes to me
and and clearly they're having problems
and often you can see right away why
they're having problems you can't tell
them it's because you're doing this
because if they knew that they probably
wouldn't bother coming to you they're
not ready to hear that so in fact what
you have to do is lead them to a place
where they see that something they're
doing now is definitely wrong and get
them to stop doing that so if we could
actually just stop people pushing
further and further down this
cyborg path and re-humanize humanity
this would be wonderful but to do that
would require a degree of humility a
degree of or or wonder before the world
and a degree of compassion for people
who don't agree with us rather than a
kind of um high-handed narcissistic
contempt so
uh
there's a little way to go
i've been saying for a long time two
emotions that i think are missing
from my life and from lots of people's
lives or in dread
uh you know kind of the sensation that
you get when you look up at the night
sky it's this sort of insignificance
it's beauty but it's also
it's also sort of vast and unforgiving
as well so there is ore and dread that
both come up at the same time
and yeah this
the sacred
searching for meaning finding out what
it actually means to live a life here do
we have moral obligations during our
existence all of these big questions are
things that i don't know progress
it's regression not progression i think
towards making people feel fulfilled
with those now sadly we weren't able to
run census data on people in you know
2000 bc or whatever
around the battle of hastings
but
it certainly feels like the progress
that we've seen technologically in terms
of the rational worldview that we're
trying to be given here is to explain
everything away to make it into a more
sterile easy to explain lower resolution
environment
but that doesn't take into account the
fact that humans don't just need a
formula that can explain some of the
things that are going on in front of
them they need to frame that in a
broader narrative it needs to be part of
what does this mean for the fact that
this stuff exists what does it mean that
the universe is this wide and this vast
and that i am here and that i am able to
observe the universe and i am able to
know that i am an observer so on and so
forth um
so yeah i mean there's pockets there's
small pockets here in austin there's a
big sort of new age
psychedelic community of people that are
trying to that have discussions around
these topics i think are very
interesting but it very much does seem
like splinter factions as opposed to a
global movement yet
yes i i think that
my impression is that people are less
and less satisfied with the inability to
contact
um
the very real
aspect of experience that we
call the sacred the awe-inspiring and
it's often been pointed out that in fact
curiosity is he not necessarily the same
as wonder in some senses it could be the
opposite of wonder it's um how do i
work out how this this how the clock
work works here which is the opposite of
the sense of wonder you know we don't
say i'm curious what the meaning of life
should be i'm curious if there is a god
we we
we wonder and and are or inspired by
these these questions
so i mean as kant famously said there
are two great things that inspire all in
us one is the uh starry heavens without
us and the other is the moral law within
and you mentioned uh the moral law and
one of the things i
i think is terribly important and
towards the end of
this
latest book the matter with things
emphasize
is that
one way of thinking about what we're
getting wrong is that we've completely
inverted
the
pyramid of values we we worship things
like greed pleasure and manipulation
which used to be thought of as really at
the bottom of the
heap
uh with things like beauty goodness
truth and the sense of the divine at the
top instead we explain beauty goodness
and truth oh they're really just ways of
priests having power and you know all
this kind of stuff well sexual selection
well
read read my book on those questions and
i'm sure you have so um
yeah these are the parts of the problem
and i think that there is a hungering
and a for something meatier more
philosophically rich and deep than this
very thin gruel that we've had at the
moment which really almost
an autistic child could come up with you
know
it's just a mechanism it's a piece of
cloth right don't get fussed about it
but there we are
do you think that there's a moral
obligation that people have while
they're existing or do you think that
there's a
uh a north star or a vector sort of
direction that people should be moving
themselves toward
i definitely think that life is a moral
business and we make moral decisions all
the time
in fact um how we pay attention to
things which is
at the core of my
understanding of the difference between
the hemispheres since they attend to the
world differently is a moral act how you
attend as a moral act because it changes
what it is you find in the world either
you miss completely its richness its
vulnerability its beauty um its capacity
and and potential
and or you or you are aware of those and
equally it changes you so certain kinds
of attention paid to the world
impoverish the world and impoverish us
they make us um cruel simple um uh
blinkered people so how we attend is a
is a moral act in itself
and what we do is
morally important i believe it is
in a way
[Music]
the variety of individuals
is that each of us can has the capacity
to express another facet to unfold
another facet of the infinitely complex
hole that is this cosmos
and um
in something i've only got to
come to grips with
fairly recently in my uh
intellectual history is um
the kabbalah the
the the judaic mystical literature
in which one of the core images is that
of vessels that have shattered which
contain sparks of light from the divine
and that it is a human
um role during this life to piece
together
what has been shattered in order to make
these vessels more beautiful than they
were before they were broken i think
that's very beautiful and it brings to
mind for me this japanese art called
kintsugi where if of
ours has been broken it can be mended
using lines of gold which make it more
complex and more beautiful than it was
before it was broken
so i i
can't obviously go into any more of that
but just that hint suggests to me that
actually yes our role here is profoundly
moral and if we don't realize that that
is a that's a moral failure in itself
ian mcgill christ ladies and gentlemen
if people want to keep up to date with
the stuff that you do where should they
go
well and to channelmegopis.com
um and it's having a complete overhaul
should be in its new form by the middle
or end of april and uh
yes thank you very much i appreciate you
in i really really like the stuff that
you do thank you
thanks very much chris what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you